BECAME GOOD FRIENDS.
SIR ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE,
HE WROTE SHERLOCK HOLMES...
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE,
HE WAS LIKE,
SPIRITUALISM IS THE [bleep]!
I LOVE IT!
THIS IS HOW EVERYTHING
NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS--
WHATEVER THIS RELIGION IS,
THIS NEEDS--
EVERYONE NEEDS TO KNOW THIS.
HOUDINI HELD HIS TONGUE.
HE KNEW IT WAS BULL[bleep].
SIR ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE
WAS LIKE,
I WANT YOU TO SIT DOWN
AND HAVE THIS SEANCE,
AND I HAVE--
MY WIFE IS GOING TO SPEAK
YOUR MOTHER'S WORDS
THROUGH HANDWRITING.
REALLY?
HOUDINI,
SHUT THE [bleep] UP.
JUST QUIET DOWN.
I KNOW YOU'RE SKEPTICAL.
LET'S JUST DO THIS.
- THE--
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR--
SIR ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE,
HIS WIFE IS LIKE,
YAY! WE'RE ALL HERE.
WE'RE DOING THIS SEANCE.
LET'S SPEAK
TO HOUDINI'S MOTHER.
SO THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
OH!
MY SON, I'M SO HAPPY
TO SPEAK TO YOU!
OH, THIS IS SO WONDERFUL!
OH, THANK GOD FOR YOU
AND SIR ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE!
MR. SHERLOCK--
OKAY, WELL, MOTHER, UM...
CAN YOU READ MY MIND?
[laughs]
OF COURSE!
I'VE ALWAYS READ
MY SON'S MIND.
THIS IS--THIS IS GREAT!
UH, UM, YES.
[wand clatters]
I--SORRY
I DROPPED THAT WAND.
BUT YES, I'M GONNA PUT
A CROSS ON TOP OF THIS THING.
SHE WROTE A CROSS
ON THE TOP OF THE THING.
MRS. HOUDINI WAS JEWISH.
AFTER SIR ARTHUR CONAN DOYLE
AND HIS WIFE
[bleep]ED HIM OVER,
HE REALIZED THAT...
WHO HE--
ONE, TWO, THREE--
HE--HE BECAME ANGRY.
HE'S LIKE, [bleep]!
I'M GOING TO FALSIFY
EVERY [bleep]ING SPIRITUALIST
THAT I COME ACROSS.
HOUDINI WOULD GO AROUND
IN DISGUISE